navigating through the city by boat
birmingham has a labyrinth of canals
it's said to have more waterways than
venice
they date back to the time of
industrialization crisscrossing the
entire region
skipper sydney vilma shows tourists the
sights from his narrow boat the network
is 160 kilometers long it used to be
twice that size
so many people don't know that these
canal exists this canal was built to
carry coal
have you seen the burgers
laid up there these were the bulges who
carried coal at this time they were
pulling by horses this is the shortest
uh
way of transporting call from let's say
birmingham to wolverhampton you go
straight there yeah
everywhere in england
upmarket homes are springing up along
birmingham's canals converted from
disused factories and warehouses
brindley place has become a trendy place
to go out for locals and visitors alike
some of the areas still need a bit of
work but generally this is nice it's
sort of getting that
the european kind of feel with the
outside cafes i think it's got great
diversity to be honest it's got a lot of
culture there's places like here which
is quite sort of sophisticated i suppose
then you've got a lot of good nightclubs
a lot of towns a lot of variety i think
as well as the main thing there's a lot
more new
new things here there's been a lot of
development in the city over the years
it's not perhaps the the old run-down
city that it once was i think it's had a
lot of development
in the 16th century birmingham's
population was just 1500.
it later became known as the workshop of
the world with a reputation for its
metal products
the city's later rise to industrial
powerhouse in the late 18th century was
driven by steam engine inventor james
watt in collaboration with fellow
scottish inventor william murdoch and
local manufacturer matthew bolton
birmingham now home to over a million
people was dubbed city of a thousand
trades
if we looked at birmingham in the 18th
century
birmingham is most famous for its button
manufacturer and that doesn't sound very
exciting but buttons were made here in
their millions and you know transported
around the world so in the 18th century
buttons like pearl buttons were like
little jewels really pieces of artwork
and they were used for men's clothing
predominantly so they were very high
fashion items that were kind of
transported around the world
there's still plenty of evidence
highlighting the wealth of those days
but besides beautiful works of
architecture birmingham is also not
short on concrete monstrosities
which came to dominate the cityscape in
the 20th century
that too is slowly changing birmingham
has been brushing up its image with
building projects like the new city
library which have attracted
international attention
it stands right opposite another
cultural gym the symphony hall
home to the city of birmingham symphony
orchestra
it's considered one of the finest music
venues in the world
andrus nelsons from latvia has been the
music director here for the past six
years
he's walked in the footsteps of famous
british conductor sir simon rattle who
transformed the orchestra in the 1980s
and 1990s
the city can be
and are proud of the orchestra i found
out with birmingham when there was a
young musician the city of birmingham
symphony orchestra and sir simon rattle
that's what i knew about birmingham when
i was 10 12 years old it's kind of comes
together
many exciting things but it is i think
this is the the first which
presents represents
city
birmingham is also famous for its
cuisine locals say that balti curries
were invented not in pakistan as many
believe but here in the so-called balti
triangle
shabab's restaurant run by zafar hussein
still serves up balti's using the
original recipe from the 1970s
a wok-type multi-bowl is used to make it
and is what gives the dish its name
everyone sort of got on the balti
bandwagon thinking yeah you know so
everyone's got on their signs balti
balti balti but um which is why we are
we are there's a few restaurants working
together including uh myself we're
trying to go for the eu um patent so
it's recognized as a
balti and so not anyone can just call it
a balti so you've got to take
precautions and do things in a set
manner set way
in order for you to call a dish a balti
curry has long been one of britain's
favorite foods
now perhaps one day birmingham balti
will even be considered officially part
of europe's culinary heritage